this is a day
i've been looking forward to for two and
a half years
[Applause]
every once in a while a revolutionary
product comes along
that changes everything
and
apple has been
well first of all one's very fortunate
if you get to work on just one of these
in your career
apple's been very fortunate
it's been able to
introduce a few of these into the world
1984
we introduced the macintosh
it didn't just change apple
it changed the whole computer industry
in 2001
we introduced the first ipod
and
it didn't just
didn't just change the way we all listen
to music
it changed the entire music industry
well
today
we're introducing
three
revolutionary products of this class
the first one
[Applause]
is a widescreen ipod with touch controls
the second
is a revolutionary mobile phone
and the third
is a breakthrough internet
communications device
so
three things
a widescreen ipod with touch controls
a revolutionary mobile phone and a
breakthrough internet communications
device
an ipod
a phone
and an internet communicator
an ipod
a phone
are you getting it
these are not
three separate devices
this is one device
and we are calling it
iphone
today
today apple is going to reinvent the
phone
and here it is
no
actually here it is but we're gonna
leave it there for now
so
before we get into it
let me uh
let me talk about a category of things
the most advanced phones are called
smart phones
so they say
and uh they typically combine a phone
plus some email capability plus they say
it's the internet sort of the baby
internet into one device and they all
have these plastic little keyboards on
them uh and the problem is
that they're not so smart
and they're not so easy to use so if you
kind of make a
you know business school 101 graph with
a smart access and the easy to use
access phones regular cell phones are
kind of right there they're not so smart
and they're you know not so easy to use
um
but smartphones are definitely a little
smarter but they actually are harder to
use they're really complicated just for
the basic stuff people have a hard time
figuring out how to use them
well we don't want to do either one of
these things
what we want to do is make a leapfrog
product
that is
way smarter than any mobile device has
ever been
and super easy to use this is what
iphone is
okay
so
we're going to reinvent the phone
now we're going to start
with a revolutionary user interface
is
the result of years of research and
development
and of course it's an interplay of
hardware and software
now
why do we need a revolutionary user
interface i mean here's four smartphones
right motorola q the blackberry
palm trail nokia e62 the usual suspects
and
what's wrong with their user interfaces
well the problem with them is really
sort of in the bottom 40 there
it's it's this stuff right here
they all have these keyboards that are
there whether you need them or not to be
there and they all have these control
buttons that are fixed in plastic and
are the same for every application well
every application wants a slightly
different user interface a slightly
optimized set of buttons just for it
and what happens if you think of a great
idea six months from now you can't run
around and add a button to these things
they're already shipped
so what do you do
it doesn't work because the buttons and
the controls can't change they can't
change for each application and they
can't change
down the road if you think of another
great idea you want to add to this
product
well how do you solve this
hmm
it turns out we have solved it we solved
it in computers 20 years ago
we solved it with a bitmap screen
that could display anything we want put
any user interface up
and a pointing device we solved it with
the mouse
right
we solve this problem so how are we
going to take this to a mobile device
well what we're going to do is get rid
of all these buttons
and just make a giant screen
a giant screen
now
how are we going to communicate this we
don't want to carry around a mouse right
so what are we going to do
oh a stylist right we're going to use a
stylus
no now
who wants a stylist
you have to get them and put them away
and you lose them yuck
nobody wants a stylus so let's not use a
stylus
we're going to use the best pointing
device in the world we're going to use a
pointing device that we're all born with
we're born with 10 of them we're going
to use our fingers
we're going to touch this with our
fingers and we have invented a new
technology called multi-touch
which is phenomenal
it works like magic
you don't need a stylus
it's far more accurate than any touch
display that's ever been shipped
it ignores unintended touches it's super
smart
you can do multi-finger gestures on it
and boy have we patented it
so
we've been very lucky
to have brought a few revolutionary user
interfaces to the market in our time
first was the mouse
the second
was the click wheel and now
we're going to bring multi-touch to the
market
and each of these revolutionary user
interfaces has made possible
a revolutionary product the mac the ipod
and now the iphone so a revolutionary
user interface we're going to build on
top of that
with software now software on mobile
phones
is like
it's like baby software
it's not so powerful
and today
we're going to show you a software
breakthrough software that's at least
five years ahead of what's on any other
phone now how do we do this well we
start
with a strong foundation iphone runs os
10.
now
why
why would we want to run such a
sophisticated operating system on a
mobile device well because it's got
everything we need
it's got multitasking it's got the best
networking it already knows how to power
manage we've been doing this on mobile
computers for years it's got awesome
security and the right apps
it's got everything from coco and the
graphics and it's got core animation
built in and it's got the audio and
video that os 10 is famous for it's got
all the stuff we want and it's built
right in to iphone and that has let us
create
desktop class applications and
networking
right
not the crippled stuff that you find on
most phones this is real desktop class
applications
now you know
one of the pioneers of our industry alan
kaye has had a lot of great quotes
throughout the years and i ran across
one of them recently that explains how
we look at this
explains why we go about doing things
the way we do because we love software
and here's the quote
people who are really serious about
software
should make their own hardware
you know
alan said this 30 years ago
and this is how we feel about it and so
we're bringing breakthrough software to
a mobile device for the first time it's
five years ahead of anything on any
other phone if you want to see how steve
jobs hires and manages people check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there the greatest people
are self-managing they don't need to be
managed you if they know what if once
they know what to do
they'll go figure out how to do it they
don't need to be managed at all what
they need is a common vision